I tell it's just off time it's just a  true Jason Bateman story you know what  he actually said last night  what'd he say we had and he said what's  what's Netflix and chill and I said hey  grandad cool Netflix in show no I didn't  go oh so we're you Netflix and chill and  I was like yeah well it's like it can  mean just hang out but it also can mean  you know come over and you know let's  get it on you know so you stopped  everything to slam Jason Bateman yeah I  just remembered after break crowd yeah  this is great  oh this is the handsomest crowd I've  ever seen how incredible  and no fans abatement here I'll tell you  that much right now good anti Bateman  American yeah  you